- Very early on,
there was only one voice
in my game, my own.
(jazzy music)
♪ Verzache ♪
And this is my biggest point to everybody.
This is why I don't allow
complaining or dwelling
for people that want to fuck with me
because no matter what,
I'm gonna point to somebody
who had the same, exact,
say oh, what?
You had a crack head father
and your mom fucking sexually abused you
and you got stabbed?
Cool, let me show you this kid
who actually had that exact
same thing and he won.
What we're talking about
right now is the reason I win.
I'm not worried about the little details.
This is all macro, blueprint,
strategy, mental strategy.
No matter what we say right now, Pete,
I'm gonna show you somebody who grew up
with the same exact situation,
had different outcomes.
And so for me and people
that who's dwelling
on their shortcoming,
the bottom line is no
matter where you start,
everybody has paths to winning and losing.
For me, the best move is to
take control of your shit.
No matter how fucked up you are right now,
get rid of loser friends and family,
introduce yourself to
positivity and winners
and watch how it plays out.
By the way, that's the punchline.
Like this is a mental game.
Like there's just nothing else.
If you're not feeling
it, find new friends.
I'm being dead serious about this.
This one is real big for me.
Who you hang out with is a huge deal.
And these are all tried
and true things, right?
We've heard the, your the whatever
of the five friends you
spend, like that's real.
That one put in the bank.
Please understand that
mindset is controllable
in the same way that all our
opinions are controllable.
The key is to add more
people with optimism
and cut people with negativity.
It's very, very simple.
And I'm trying to figure out
how to get this for everybody,
'cause it is the, I
think it's the ultimate.
I lived in my own head.
Nobody had say.
When I tell you nobody fucking
had say, still to this day,
nobody has say, nobody has say.
Very early on, there was only
one voice in my game, my own.
It's so scary to me, how
singular my own voice is.
It doesn't mean that I
don't listen to feedback.
It doesn't mean that I'm delusional
and I think I can get away with
bad shit and it's all okay.
I could say something
right now in this podcast,
everybody under says, I'm a piece of shit.
And in my own mind, I'm like, we'll see.
It's very strange how I live life.
It's way more extreme than you think.
It's way more extreme than I think.
I'm just kind of like
going through right now.
I'm like, what the fuck? This is crazy.
It just means that I am incapable
of valuing anybody else's
opinion, including my mom's,
my wife's and my children's
opinion about me over my own.
If you realized how much
of the actions you do
is to show your mom or
your dad or your sibling
or your spouse, or somebody,
show somebody else that
you made it or you did it.
It is remarkably scary how many people
are dictated by somebody else's opinion.
The whole game's broken
because everybody's too tied up
into other people's opinions.
I only care about my opinion of myself.
I think most people do
shit for other people.
I think most people buy
the car and the house
for other people.
Do some people love the leather
of a car or the horsepower?
Yes.
Do some people like love having
a home that has nine rooms
they never use?
Sure.
But do you understand?
When you're building something,
you fucking invest in the right things
as soon as fucking possible.
The problem is most
people don't get to that
because they're, as when something starts
getting successful, they're
taking the money out
and buying dumb shit.
I've never met anybody who's been able
to penetrate my mindset and
that includes my own parents.
What's even crazier where I'm at now,
I feel like I'm this manifestation.
I feel like they made me,
but then I mutated into something else.
I don't value anybody's opinion about me
more than I have about my own self.
And it's a very big deal.
There's nothing like it,
man. There's nothing like it.
I don't know what else to say.
It is the ultimate drug. It
is the ultimate leverage.
It's exactly what you're talking about.
That's exactly what I'm doing.
People don't get it.
Like, life's basic and
we make it complicated.
And it starts with being
right in your own mind.
It's such an inside game.
It's an inside game.
Just add more people with
positivity and optimism
and cut people with
pessimism and cynicism.
Who you surround yourself matters.
What content you consume matters.
I basically suffocate myself
for a long period of my time
and created an environment
that was based on offense
and optimism and now I know no different.
I just don't give a fuck
what anybody thinks.
Now I equally care so
much of how they view me
and what they think of me,
it's pulling from opposite directions.
But you got to start with yourself
because when you're actually allowing
other people to get in, you're vulnerable.
(upbeat music)